hello everyone and happy Valentine's Day
everyone
now we have an excellent game here
between once again Lila just zero in
stockfish as you all know we've covered
a few games about Lila in the past few
days Lila won the 2019 TCC Cup that
season 14 and now we have the super
finest Lila faces the strongest version
of stockfish in a series of 14 games not
14 its season 14 in a series of 100
games and this is game 49 in the first
48 games the the score is 24 to 24 so so
far I Lila is tied with stockfish this
is game 49 a very exciting game and it's
a very complex game so I'll try to you
know colorize it let's put it that way
as to the best of my abilities but I
really think it's just all about the end
game and it's gonna fit right into our
capablanca saga as well it's just a
wonderful middle game that leads to a to
a dominant end game so I do hope you
enjoyed that as well now let's check it
out as we've already mentioned the
openings are predefined so here we'll
have a nice benoni
with d 4 d 4 belly latin Knight to f6 C
4 now we have East 6 9 253 and c5
through a bit of a different move order
but d5e captures C captures and now d6
and with Knight to c3 we have a amount
of variation of the of the benoni
defense we have g6 Bishop to f4 with
with some ideas of maybe attacking it
this pawn in the future but most likely
this night is coming to d2 and then
later to c4 to help out with the attack
against the d6 pawn if black allows it
but if black plays everything correctly
of course the black will not allow that
Bishop to g7 and now like I said you can
go for the point immediately due to this
Queen a5 check now you'll have to go
back with the night otherwise you're
gonna lose the night and then Knight
capture some d5 I just win the pawn for
black here you can capture with the
Queen but then bunch of captures you
don't want to lose the rook so you have
to play the bishop back captures
captures and here black will just be
upon up so after Bishop to g7 we have
Queen to a4 check by Lyra forcing the
bishop
out and only after Bishop to d7 now
point to b3 the Queen is now nicely
developed and already attacking the b7
pawn we have Queen to c7 defending and
now comes a four and here castles and
this is nothing new this has been played
by human players over and over again
throughout the chess history we have
Knight the d2 preparing this night to
either come to c4 but for the moment
it's helping out with with the defense
of the e4 pawn Knight to h5 pressuring
the brush up on f4 and the bishop goes
back to a 3 also with Knight to h5
stockfish made room for this pawn to
come to f5 so now comes f5 Leah's King
is still in the center so it makes
perfect sense to bust open the center we
have a captures Bishop captures and now
comes h3 with the threat of g4 winning
the peace and this position was a reach
a few times last it was reached in 2017
in the Isle of Man tournament between
Ria's on 7 ended on chenko and here nice
back to f6 was played to not not allow
g4 to count with black losing the piece
but here stockfish played Bishop to d7
and it's as of this moment move 14 we
have a completely new game
s'okay we're Knight dt4 Lila's plan is
now to develop the light square bishop
and this night will at some point come
from g5 all the way to East 6 on e6 this
night will become a monster and the
white will of course have to eliminate
it at some point and then Lila will be
able to create a very strong pass pawn
on e6 this is the plan so first King to
h6 o King to h8 you don't want to allow
this King to stand this diagonal and now
not Bishop to e2 or d3 because we
already explained the plan but here also
this will just give black to easier game
either you would have to give up your
dark square Bishop which is not
something you want to do with the blacks
weakened King side the dark square
Bishop is a very strong piece and you
will either have to now waste the tempo
or or play a bishop somewhere you don't
want to or defend the bishop and then
black will again eliminate white
submission up there so as planned Lila
goes to Bishop to c4 we have a 6
preparing b5 of course Lila prevents
this a4
and now comes Russia back to a five now
there's no problem of white playing g4
because you can always capture the night
night captures night at four and all is
well here black can now achieve pretty
much everything black once the night is
coming back into the game the rooks will
be connected and the game will be quite
you know quite enjoyable for black so
after Bishop to a5 Leela continues with
the plan Knight to g5 now the night is
coming to e6 we have Queen to e7 not
allowing the nights to come t7 wouldn't
attack on the Queen but also pressuring
White's King that is still in the center
you try playing a game up until move 18
with your king honey one against dogfish
so finally Lila castles and now Knight
to d7 and here we have Knights to e6
finally the night is here and now
perhaps this is playable without
capturing the knight but forever young
human standards you do not want this
night to be an e6 where white can just
leave it there for as long as so white
likes or or give up the the bishop and
g7 which is a very strong piece as we
already mentioned Bishop captures was
played with D captures now as we said
this now pawn is promoted to a very
strong past ecig spawn and Knights the
e5 pressuring the bishop here and now
comes a rush up to d5 pressuring the b7
pawn so Knight to c6 blocking the
bishops attack towards the pawn and rook
81 now leave us all we lost pieces are
developed still there's the question of
rook on f1 but for the time being it's
fine where it is rook 88 again you don't
want this Bishop on the rook on this
diagonal and also perhaps a b5 will be
an idea later on we have nights that
efore and now comes night back to f6 and
here you might think oh it's an
excellent opportunity to go Knight to g5
with some threats of Knight to f7 but
white it doesn't really have any threats
here for example if knife captures
Bishop Queen captures Eden Roc f5 just
attacks the Queen and also pressures the
night Queen moves now comes King to g8
and white it doesn't really have any
threats here the black can even push
back the night with h6 whenever black
once and the night is pretty much stuck
there defending
this ISA spawn for the moment so first
Bishop to g5 just pinning the night here
and there's also a lot of pressure
against this night nights the before
with a double attack against the bishop
and now comes Knight to c3 and here
black cannot you know exchange some
pieces in the center to alleviate the
pressure because if you play Knight
captures here then you get Knight
captures and black is lost there's
really nothing to do here
your queen is under attack you cannot
capture because the knight is pinned if
you go here is seven attacks the Queen
and the rook this will of course be
winning even if you go Queen 87 still
wins the game your rook is under attack
after you move it can your sonar get
Bishop captures Bishop captures an hour
night c7 forcing the Queen to move and
then the pawn will promote let's say
Queen g8 now you bring the Queen into
the game rook captures you can capture
with the rook threatening to win the
Queen after rook a fate you can go look
after screen captures and now after rook
to e1 here just up a hole rook of course
a completely winning game for Leela
so after Knight c3 you cannot capture we
have h6 forcing Layla to decide what to
do with the bishop and of course you
don't want to go back
so Bishop captures on f6 with rook
captures on f6 and now comes g3
preparing perhaps f4 and h4 and here we
have rook beat ae8 I thought rugby to f8
would we would be a nice move here
obviously not a stock free decides to go
for this rook to e8 move perhaps after
the Queen moves top which wants to play
this rook to e7 to block the e6 pawn but
also to keep an eye on the b7 pawn as
for now the knight cannot move as the
Queen is also pressuring the pawn
alongside with the bishop but okay with
h4 here rook to f5 and now Bishop goes
back to g2 as well the knight and the
local are pressuring the bishop here so
there's no reason for Bishop to stay
there it's much safer on g2 we have
Bishop to d4 pressuring now DF to pawn
as you can see now it's quite useful
that it's this rook that's an f1 not
that
this rook remain here and that Lila
played this rook to e1 so like we said
for the moment that this rook on f1 is
is quite useful still with 92 attacking
the bishop and now comes a five and now
you could capture here a doubling black
spawns but there's no rush
first the Bishop to h3 attacking
stockfish rook on f5 will rip the e5 now
and out Knight captures on d4 seek
actress and now Queen to c4 pressuring
the d4 pawn Knight to c6 Knights defends
the pawn and now comes the Queen back to
d3 attacking the g6 pawn and now Queen
the g7 defending and we have rook to e4
now a nice rook lift also look to g4
will be a very nice idea creating a
double attack again the g6 pawn but also
now this rook is welcome to join the
game rook the c5 and here comes King to
g2 we have rook to e7
like we said perhaps this is one of the
reasons why that rook to e8 instead of
rope to f8 was played but who knows
we have rook F the e1 Leela doubles
rooks on the e-file and now comes Queen
to f8 we have looked the g4 with a
double attack against the g6 pawn and
now comes hook to e5 with the idea that
well if rope captures Knight captures
also protects the g6 pawn but now Lilla
can actually capture here and pin the
night so the knight cannot capture here
this would this would win Leela the pawn
for the moment but it allows some ideas
with Queen to f3 chick and then you
don't know if you will be able to
untangle here so after rook to e5 we
have first looked to F for attacking
stockfish Queen on f8 and now comes
Queen to d8 and now rook the c1 so Leela
keeping keeping the pressure its
stockfish to move
we've looked to g7 not not a lot of
things to do here now comes Queen to b3
a very nice move and now comes Queen to
e7 again
just blocking the pawn keeping an eye on
the b7 pawn and here comes Bishop to g4
we have h5 attacking the bishop bishop
to f3 and now what do you do here this
was Leila's plan and now Bishop captures
on c6 is a real
as black would lose upon so Lila decides
to give up this pawn for some excellent
counter play and for taking this game
into into a very favorable end game
night d8 now attacking the e6 pawn but
first look to see it now pinning the
knight King to h7 unpinning and now
first rook captures on d4 just grabbing
this pawn Knight captures on e6
eliminating finally this very strong
east exponent with an attack on the rook
and now rook to d5 Knight the c5
attacking the Queen Queen d2 and now
captures on d5 Queen captures on d5 and
this is the position allele a storm that
was more favorable than that one where
she grabs a pawn and allows the Queen f3
check here Stoker's played Queen to f6
and allowed Lila to go for this Bishop
captures on h5 why did stockfish allow
this this is also a very important idea
the problem is rook e8 can attack the a
five point it's it's it's impossible to
properly defend the D a five point so
here if you tried something let's say
Queen d7 attacking the rook rook goes to
eight you defend b6 but now rugby eight
and after Queen c7 it seems like black
is doing perfectly alright this rope
will now have to move or keep on going
places but Queen a8 and now there is no
defense against a rock to h8 checkmate
this is one of the problems with with
stockfish position here you you cannot
avoid this you can go look f7 but then
just brush of b5 wins the rook if you if
you move it further then it will of
course be checkmate so uh there's a lot
of poison to the position so that's why
after the screen captures and e5
Stockbridge decided on a different line
of defense Queen f6 and allows this
Bishop captures on h5 and it's very
interesting that this line does not lose
material for stalkerish it just gives
Lyra a favourable end game because now
okay you cannot capture
do you see what happens and how white
wins if you capture the pawn even feel
free to pause the video here and it's a
nice little tactic and so the position
for white white is winning this for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are excellent winner
of Queens and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show
it's actually
screen captures and after the Queen
blocks who wrote a tray to check this is
the more we had to find after King
captures black loses the Queen and it's
all over now black can just keep playing
the game or you know resigned with
dignity and allow this very nice
checkmate so after a bunch of captures
on h5 we have Queen to f7 offering a
queen trade now Lila has to accept it
with Queen captures rook captures and
now even Bishop to d1 defending the a4
pawn but it does not keep material
allele eyes up up opponent for the
moment but black has Knight to d3
attacking the b2 and F to pawn so F for
defending the pawn has the rook was also
attacking it Knight captures and now
bush of the sea to the threat is of
course h5 as the g6 pawn is pinned
we have King the g7 and now King to f3
so now if you look at this position this
is the position Lewis so the position
that the material is equal on the board
but there are a few key differences Lila
has two point islands and the stock fish
has three point islands which is while
the rooks are still on the board a
highly favourable for the white rook as
the rook will be very happy attacking
all of these pawns and he will just
gobble all of them up on the other hand
Leo has a bishop against a stock fish
night and when the play is on both sides
sides of the board of course this favors
the bishop so d5 stock first starts
pushing the past pawn we have looked a
c5 now attacking both both of the pawns
here look the d7 stock fish puts the
rook behind the pass pawn as that's how
it's done and now just the g4 we have d4
stock fish continuous pushing the past
pawn but now just a rook the b5
attacking the knight here Knight to c4
and now Bishop to d3 blocking the pawn
and also attacking the knight
so the pawn cannot be pushed any further
we have looked the c7 defending and now
comes h5g captures on h5 and now rook
captures on h5 not allowing the pawn
structure to be messed up and now you
can see that the material is still equal
on the board but the two connected
passed pawns legal has on the King side
are are simply well very powerful
rook the c6 but now rook to h7 check the
bishop is protecting the rook here we
have King to f8 and now even rook
captures this pawn Knight to d6 rook to
a7 attacking this pawn now comes rook to
c3
King defends the bishop and now rook to
a3 there's not all that much you can do
here rook captures an e5 is played and
now stock which is just losing pawn by
pawn rook Lee to check a few more moves
were played King he won rook e1 check
King bee to a rook a to check King goes
to c1 now preparing to attack the rook
rook e3 and now we have looked the d5
offering the bishop for a knight Knight
b7 but now rook captures on d4 Knight
sorry Knights the c5 double attack on
the bishop bishop see two knights the e6
and now just Rock the c4 this is now
completely winning the rook is defending
all of the pawns and white is just up so
many pawns so a few more moves were
played 90 g7 we have G 5 here Knights
the e8 was played we have g6 here and
after King to g7 kink the b2 was played
attacking the rook and after rook to a3
it was in this position that stockfish
resigned the game yes let's all say it
together it was in this position that
stockfish resigned the game not not a
lot of times you will hear this but yeah
an excellent victory for Leah and this
is the first time in the match game 49
that Leela is now in the lead in this
100 game match
so if Leela will be able to win this
Leela will be the TC ec2000 season 14
champion and someone mentioned on
Twitter I forgot who it was but I saw
the tweet someone said that the had the
magical power versus Karpov was a you
know shut down after 48 games because it
was simply unable to continue and now in
game 49 Leela takes the lead so AI
doesn't mind they can play just you know
a million games if needed
and I like I said in the description
below there will be a link to really
watch a zero blog where you can follow
up on on Leila's progress and also the
first thing the first link in the
description below will be a link where
you can follow live alive at this game
between Lila and stockfish they are all
young game I believe 50/50 - perhaps I
believe and legalize now even 2 points
in elite so we'll be showing some more
games of HL 0 oh yeah that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Allen Black Rock remaining but not
more young wish coughs key and bearers
for your contribution to my channel
thanks a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check - on my previous
videos here think all for watching and I
will see you soon hopefully with some
more interesting content will check up
on allele it shows zero but also of
course continuing the capablanca saga
thank you all and I will see you soon